Andrés muy buenos días bueno como este
cerca de 3.500 centros de votación en
toda Guatemala han oficialmente abierto
sus puertas para recibir a 9.3 millones
de guatemaltecos que están empadronados
para este día electoral todos los ojos
están puestos en quienes de los tres
candidatos a la presidencia más
opcionados pasarán a segunda vuelta y
aquí se juegan su destino edmon mulet
Sandra Torres y Suri Ríos pero son cinco
papeletas de diferentes colores porque
los guatemaltecos también eligen
alcaldes diputados al congreso diputados
al parlamento centroamericano Y a lo
largo del día veremos cuan masivas o
cuan escasas puedan ser las
participaciones electorales en este día
de los comicios debido a que se llega a
un día electoral con alta desconfianza
por parte de la ciudadanía en las
instituciones y sobre todo en El
Ejecutivo sobre el presidente Alejandro
yamatei recae una popularidad en su
contra una desaprobación del 75% Esta es
la más baja de los presidentes en
América Latina y un dato adicional es
que en Estados Unidos cerca de 90.000
guatemaltecos están habilitados a votar
en diferentes ciudades del país 15 de
ellas como Miami como Nueva York y Los
Ángeles muchos de ellos temen que
ocurran redadas de migrantes para
deportarlos pero el tribunal supremo
electoral ha dicho que Guatemala ha
llegado a un acuerdo con Estados Unidos
para que este escenario no ocurra Andrés
hay preocupaciones sobre un posible
fraude electoral que nos puede decir al
respecto
Bueno sobre estas preocupaciones hubo un
nuevo capítulo esta semana por cuenta de
la publicación de un artículo del New
York Times en donde se revela que de un
posible soborno que habría hecho uno de
los hombres más cercanos aliados al
presidente Alejandro yamaté y Miguel
Martínez a una de las magistradas de el
tribunal supremo electoral Blanca Alfaro
en el año 2022 para ingerir inferir
dentro de los comicios que hoy se están
realizando sin embargo después de la
publicación tanto la magistrada como el
hombre Aliado de yamatei han negado lo
sucedido queda entonces en las fuentes
de la embajada de los Estados Unidos
donde se habría presentado esta denuncia
y aunado a esto pues está el el hecho de
un posible fraude electoral anticipado
de lo que tanto se ha hablado en las
últimas semanas y es de haber dejado por
fuera a tres de los candidatos
presidenciales que habían representado
una amenaza para la establecimiento para
el denominado pacto productos aquí en
Guatemala está Carlos Pineda el
empresario antisistema que en mayo
estaba despuntando mayo estaba liderando
las encuestas también la líder indígena
de izquierda Telma Cabrera y el delfín
político que es uno de los férreos
opositores de yamatei Roberto arzú con
la salida de estos tres candidatos pues
organismos internacionales han puesto su
voz de denuncia de que hay un posible
fraude electoral y por su parte el
tribunal supremo electoral ha dicho que
pues se han tomado las decisiones
correspondientes a la ley y que para hoy
no va a haber ningún fraude electoral
Por quienes Quienes cuentan las
papeletas quienes registran los votos
son los propios ciudadanos en todos los
centros de votación dispuestos